well full disclosure julian assange is a
personal friend of mine
uh and when i could no longer go into
the embassy to see him i stood outside
and sang frank sinatra songs to him
through the window
i'm actually not a bad singer and julian
likes frank sinatra
julian assange is
a world historic figure
whatever happens in this court case he
has developed an entirely new model of
journalism
one which facilitates the
exposure of material and information
that the powerful don't want to see
disclosed and
that is the very definition of
journalism
if nobody doesn't want you to say what
you're saying
and doing then what you're saying and
doing probably isn't worth
a raw beans because
if it's not hurting someone somewhere
amongst the powerful of what you are
revealing
then it's probably not worth revealing
and so julian
in during the time that i have been his
friend
has revealed some of the most
sensational
material uh ever only some of which he's
on trial for
uh he's essentially on trial now
for revealing war crimes committed by
the united states and others in the
invasion and occupation of iraq and
afghanistan which
when i started out opposing it was a
deeply unpopular stance
mine i could show him as cars
but you can now now not find a sentient
being in the land
who any longer thinks that invading and
occupying iraq was a good idea
but julian during that period
when things were different
revealed big crimes
systemic crimes in the war logs
which showed mass killing of civilians
of journalists a totally cavalier
attitude to wiping people out whether
they were
men women or children whether they were
reuters reporters
whether they were prisoners being
forced to commit indecent acts upon each
other in the abu ghraib prison
and be photographed for the
entertainment
of the torturers afterwards and
videotaped and so on julian broke all
these stories
he also broke a lot of stories this is
why i'm a bit surprised that donald
trump is
pursuing him with the gusto that he
is i still live by the way in hope that
donald trump will pardon him he also
revealed
although he's not on trial for this the
absolute
venality of the clinton crime gang
and the so-called democratic party in
the united states of
america and sure that benefited trump
but it benefited all of us to know that
hillary clinton was a crook and that the
clinton crime family were up to the neck
in all kinds of
vice venality and corruption
we all needed to know that not least
because they were
secular saints in western society
julian revealed uh many
stories which cast these people
in a new life for which he now faces
175 years in a super max prison
in the united states so this story is
important
and yet entirely ignored by the very
liberal class of journalists and
broadcasters that
feasted on the dripping roast of his
revelations
and so if you were going to ask me who
do i hate most
in the whole world i'd tell you the
guardian
the guardian newspaper personifies
everything that i hate in society and
one of the reasons
is the guardian feasted on julian's
stories
ran them over and over again on the
front page
of their newspaper and have remained
utterly silent while he's persecuted
prosecuted and banished forever into the
bowels
of a super max prison even though
that very process may one day be used
against them and could be i mean if
julian has committed an offence
in publishing these stories so have they
in publishing these stories
their editor could now be on trial maybe
one day will be
and if we get to a situation where our
country it's america today
it could be saudi arabia tomorrow
saudi arabia could for example
i was a good friend of adnan khashoggi
who was
murdered by the saudi dictatorship and
literally cut into pieces and flushed
into a drain
but when he was living here in london
and in fact he was living in washington
when that happened to him
the saudis could have sought his
extradition to
saudi arabia now you might say it's
fanciful that any british court would
send someone to saudi arabia
it's not that fanciful if you could send
someone to 175 years
in a super max in america if the saudis
had said we won't cut his head off
we'll only put them in prison for 175
years
they could have extradited uh adnan
khashoggi
might have been better than the end that
he had
but it could happen to anybody it could
happen to you could happen to you
you're seditious
here seditious to somebody
you know that would make a lot of people
very happy so it could well
lead to some foreign power
extraditing you and destroying you
now when this unequal extradition treaty
was concluded in secret
in summer when the house was not sitting
by david blunkett tony blair's home
secretary
you may say i am a soothsayer
i personally raised with david blanket
emotional because i didn't know julian
at that time
a notional case whereby
a journalist whistleblower could be
extradited
without just cause being needed to be
shown could be extradited to the united
states
under this extradition treaty
david blanket gave me a personal
assurance
that it was on the face of the bill that
no one could be
extradited for a political crime
in his secret extradition treaty that
was signed before
we even knew existed how's that for
parliamentary democracy
i was an mp at the time for here
actually uh this very street
and he said to me showed me the
declaration on the face of the bill on
the face of the treaty
that this could not happen my fear could
never
come to pass but it has come to pass
and the get out
is well he's not being extradited for a
political crime he's being extradited
for
effectively espionage even though he's
not a citizen of the united states
and never set foot there never committed
any crime there
um and so the promises
sick transit gloria david blanket where
is he now
what are wha what were his promises
worth
they were not worth the paper that they
were written on
and so if you believe in freedom of
speech if you believe in journalism
if you believe in the right of the
public to know
what is being done in their name on
their dollar you need to be concerned
about what's happening to julian assange
and lastly
you call me old-fashioned i believed
still to some extent believe that the
last
uncorrupted institution in great britain
was the judiciary i know the social
caste from which they come
i know they're not elected and cannot be
removed
but when i look at how all our
institutions have failed one after the
other
the civil service the media
even the police they've all failed us
one after the other
i thought the one that was left was the
judiciary i always used to say
and my father before me actually long
before these institutions
uh failed i'd rather take my chances in
front of a british judge
than in front of a british politician or
a british journalist
or any of a british police officer and
so on
and therefore the abuse of process
on openly
if you care enough to look at it in this
case
has been so gargantuan i'll give you
just one example
because time is running
if i told you that you could be
extradited even though
it is established fact that all of your
meetings
with your lawyers were filmed
by the prosecuting authority in the
united states or their
agents so they know all of what your
defense is
i speak as one who was secretly filmed
in the embassy
having a pee talk everything i said was
filmed
i can live with that but julian's
lawyers
were secretly filmed talking to him
preparing
him and he preparing them
for his defense in a court case that
might one day have to take place in
london
you would say such a case would have to
be thrown up
even if it was a traffic offense it
would have to be thrown out
if the police were filming you and your
discussions with your lawyers
but that happened nobody disputes that
it happened
all the evidence has been
laid in front of this court in london at
the old bailey
the old lady of british justice but it
will not make a blind bit
of difference the fact that such an
abusive process
that could give you 500 other abuses of
process that have happened
has not made any impact on this case
means that we have to fear
for the justice system in our own
country
itself and we not you
me someone wholly british
were led to believe and did believe that
british justice was really
something that it was justice that that
statue at top of the old bailey
of uh of uh the lady with the scales
really was something turns out it wasn't
turns out it seems unless
in the appeal process this is overturned
that julian is going to be sent to 175
years in prison
for the crime of telling the truth